we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that
they're endowed by the creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness it's this amazing second
sentence of the declaration of
independence that jefferson and adams
and franklin
wrote as part of a committee and we were
looking at that sentence let's go on to
look at that phrase they are endowed by
their creator
it's interesting they they don't really
mention you know jesus christ and not
even god they talk about the laws of
nature and of nature's god and of
creator these are deists people kind of
believe in the notion that there's some
grand creator of the universe but they
don't get into the specifics of any
particular religious
dogma the other thing is they're
balancing where do our rights come from
in an earlier draft and we'll talk about
how they edit the earlier drafts in a
later video but in an earlier draft they
just it just says they're endowed with
certain inalienable rights and you see
that john adams probably is the one who
wants to insert the phrase their creator
and that was because they started the
sentence with we hold these truths to be
sacred but they change that to
self-evident they're trying to say to
what extent is it rationality that gives
us these rights to what extent are these
rights endowed by god and i think what
they finally come down to is that we all
had a creator and those creator that
creator made us all and so to a certain
thing we're created equal our creator
must love us all we are all created by
the same creator therefore there's a
certain equality that we have and in
creating us he gave us certain
unalienable rights and unalienable this
means can't be taken away it's it can be
separated you can't it can't be
separated you can't take these rights
away the king can't take these rights
away in other words it's not as if we
could give up these rights and in
particular they are talking about this
theory of government that john locke had
who was one of the philosophers that
they read an english philosopher of that
period who said that when you create a
government or there is a government you
give up some of your rights for example
if we all agree that we're part of a
government we may give up our right say
to uh you know
take somebody else's property or
whatever it may be
so these are rights you can give up but
there are certain rights that are
unalienable that you just can't give up
or the king can't take it away once
again you got to look at thomas
jefferson who actually owns slaves at
this point and he's saying among those
unalienable rights are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness so there's this
inherent conflict still
between rights such as liberty that you
can't take away from a person and yet
jefferson's writing this phrase when he
owns slaves
the phrase life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness is also something that
derives from john locke and these
philosophers of the enlightenment that
we're writing in england at one point
john locke uses the phrase life liberty
and the pursuit of property
uh because you know locke believed that
owning property
was an important right you had and the
government couldn't just take your
property away
however you can see that they change it
to a
more sort of elevated phrase that we
each get to pursue our own notion of
what we want to do in our lives
our happiness i don't think they just
mean happiness like joy and frivolity i
think they mean pursuit of meaning in
life what gives our life meaning and
these are the unalienable rights
then they go on and this gets to what's
called the contract notion of government
is that why do we have governments and
whether it's john locke or the other
philosophers we've talked about they say
the reason we have government
is that we all had these rights but we
decided to get together we instituted
governments governments are instituted
on men and the reason those governments
have their power is because of the
consent of the govern it's like if you
and i and 20 people got together and
formed a group and we said we're going
to form a group we'll give up some of
our rights because the group itself will
have certain powers but we're consenting
to do that it's not because of the
divine right of kings it's a consent of
govern of the govern the consent of the
people says we will institute a
government amongst ourselves
and that's not to take away our rights
that's to secure our rights right we i
might the 20 of us might give up our
right to uh
to kind of enforce things police each
other to the government so that we could
have our life liberty in pursuit of
happiness we're more likely to have it
secured and once you get to that theory
you have to say what are the type of
rights we would give up such as maybe
the right to decide the traffic laws or
the policing of the thing or how
property contracts are made but there
are certain things that no matter what
you did if you were instituting a
government among men
you would not give up the right to life
you would not give up the right to
liberty and you would not say i'm going
to give up my right to be to pursue my
own
life ends my own happiness you would say
we want to secure those rights we're not
going to give those up to government i
see